all week the house oversight chair has
been dropping breadcrumbs Tuesday after
being hit with years of stonewalling
Congressman James Comer revealed that
the treasury Department was giving him
the first suspicious activity activity
report related to Hunter Biden and the
Biden family's foreign business dealings
later in the week he confirmed some
reporting for Miranda Devine's book
about a payment made by cefc a Chinese
energy firm to Hunter Biden's business
associate Rob Walker you've heard about
him and then Comer took it a step
further noting that the money was then
sent directly to accounts associated
with the bidens you think that would be
the end of major Bombshells for the week
but it wasn't
the one that drug was dropped to
Wednesday to Laura you simply won't
believe
at the end of this I think we're going
to see there are probably six or seven
Biden family members that were involved
in various business schemes around the
world
wow well we knew about Hunter we knew
about Joe's brother James but Comer
revealing that it could be six or seven
Biden family members is massive news and
last night we learned the identity of
one of the unknowns who got this money
from China beau's Widow and Hunter's
ex-girlfriend Halle Biden we know that
there are at least four more payments
from 2017 to an unknown Biden I wonder
who that is the payments range from 5
000 to 25
000 each now's oversight committee's
next move may put us closer to finding
out who that is they just asked Hunter
Biden's business associate Rob Walker
the guy shuffling all of this money
around to testify under oath in front of
the committee so how is Joe Biden
handling this knowing that the entire
thing is starting to unravel well we got
a reaction from him late last night
family deal
contributors business associates sent
over a million dollars to three of their
family members
that's not true
well that was just hours ago and here's
the problem Joe your son's own attorney
admits that this is true here's a
statement Hunter Biden a private citizen
with every right to pursue his own
business Endeavors join several business
partners in Seeking a joint venture with
a privately owned legitimate Energy
company in China Hunter received his
portion of good faith seed funds which
he shared with his uncle James Biden and
Halle Biden with whom he was involved
with at the time and sharing expenses
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else